foreign
it's time now for CBS deals and this
morning we have products that may may
you may find reaching for every day and
all at exclusive low prices to start
shopping now scan the QR code on your
screen or visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle expert sukanya
Krishnan joins us now with more good
morning to you so nice to see you Dana I
want everybody to head on over to
cbsdeals.com because these These are
really really good and they're not going
to last I'm telling you well and we're
starting with something every Chef needs
yes good knives great knives we're
talking about the caloric Cobra knives
okay all right take a look at them pick
them up first of all they're beautiful
to look at these are Hand Forged
Japanese knives yeah they're beautiful
to look at and they're easy to use yes
you're looking at that as well I'm going
to cut some apple for Michelle and Jeff
over there which is fantastic you're
welcome so we have we've got these three
different sets here for you so we've got
the five inch tone tuku and the seven
inch for you we've got the paring knife
we've got the prep knife and we've got
the chef knife we also have steak knives
that are on the website as well and and
for our viewers this morning we are
throwing in the sharpness I was just
going to say that's the thing you need
absolutely because you can have a great
set of knives but you know what it
always needs maintenance and we're
talking about high quality for a
fraction of the price on cbsdeals.com
you want to know what I'm telling you
about okay let's look at the savings
right now we're looking at an exclusive
deal of 22 to 38 dollars twenty two
dollars to thirty eight dollars for
knives and we're looking at a 38
discount that's crazy crazy good run
water bottle on steroids get your drink
on get your drink on that's what it's
all about it's about hydration to
another level I love this because it
holds me accountable so if you look at
it right here yeah it says eight o'clock
nine o'clock how much you should be
drinking and have you had this yet I've
used it I've used it all week long and
I've actually found out how much I'm not
drinking this is a half a gallon right
here what's also amazing about the drink
not only is it PBA free look at all the
handy dandy Pockets you can put your
cell phone you could put your credit
card you could put your key ring you can
put your earbuds it comes with this
incredible case that comes in different
colors and also the best part about this
you can put it over your shoulder just
take it with you and take it with you or
you can wear it as a backpack hiking
hiking as a backpack you could just put
it on your back so it comes and it's
great for the kids to take to school I'm
just telling you so this is a great deal
discount price 50 off everybody and
we're looking at 39.99 and also great
for the environment no more water
bottles going I know you were yelling at
me before because that's what I do I
know so I want you to get your drink on
I will try it on I will try tech Gadget
inspired by an octopus yes you want to
play with this yes because it's it's
amazing it's bendable it just morphs
into everything that you want to sort of
put it on top of anything and basically
it's a mount for your smartphone so you
could stream your device and look at
this everybody it has a Bluetooth remote
up to 30 feet away it connects to your
phone so if you're a content creator if
you wanted somebody who's going to take
selfies it holds up to 42 pounds so you
can mount this anywhere I actually was
washing dishes talking to my mom and
look like it's a woman cooking at the
same time and I was able to do all of it
hands-free I think it's great for the
hearing impaired too so there's you
could put it on your car mount bike
travel of people now on planes how about
just on the planes you can stream
whatever you want my daughter put it in
the back of the car and hooked it on
like this and was watching her favorite
show because I was on the pickup line
and that's never fun but you know what
the tentacle makes it fun because you
know what it takes your devices and
takes it to your home very practical yes
exactly how much are we talking we're
talking about 33 off discount and we're
looking at 23.49 to
29.99 so go to cbsdeals.com they're good
I want you to do this I want you to have
I'm sorry about this
of course we partner with all of these
companies to get these deals to buy
anything that you saw today scan the QR
code on your screen or head over to
cbsdeals.com